[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute
mitmietri Sirin Ihnen allen einen
schönen guten Abend das sportliche mit
Extraportion Fußball-WM Spiel mit dir
Christian echt spannend heute Kroatien
jubelt guten Abend dann blicken wir
jetzt auf die Themen an diesem Montag
Streit unter Freunden die EU kritisiert
geplante us-subventionen für heimische
Firmen heute ein Krisentreffen dazu
werbetor beim Milliarden Volk
Außenministerin Werbung sucht den
Schulterschluss mit Indien beißt beim
reizt Thema russisches Öl aber auf
Granit
und WM Krimi im Elfmeterschießen Japan
verpatzt gleich drei Elfer Favorit
Kroatien steht damit in Katar im
Viertelfinale
[Musik]
die weltgrößten Handelsbeziehungen die
gibt es zwischen den USA und der EU nach
Washingtons Ankündigung ein massives
milliardenprogramm aufzulegen das nur
Produkte made in USA subventioniert
könnte aber Sand ins Getriebe kommen und
genau darüber sprechen gerade Vertreter
bei der Seiten in den USA Brüssel ist
jedenfalls alarmiert und fürchtet eine
enorme Benachteiligung europäischer
Unternehmen Benjamin Daniel
ein kleiner Arbeitsraum an der
Universität von Maryland was auf den
ersten Blick recht unspektakulär
aussieht ist eines der wichtigsten
wirtschaftsgespräche zwischen den USA
und der EU auch deshalb ist
Außenminister blinken gekommen ein
Reporter fragt ihn vorab ob er glaube
den Konflikt um die Subventionen lösen
zu können seine Antwort ein Lächeln das
Problem die US-Regierung macht 370
Milliarden Dollar locker für Klimaschutz
und Energiesicherheit unter anderem
sollen Elektroautos Batterien und
weitere erneuerbare Energieprojekte
gefördert werden allerdings sollen von
den Investitionen und Steuervorteilen
nur Unternehmen profitieren die in den
USA produzieren deshalb stößt beiden
Plan in Europa auf massive Kritik
Maßnahmen ergreifen um gleiche
Bedingungen zu schaffen wo das
us-investitionspaket zu Verzerrungen
führt das
inflationsreduzierungsgesetz sollte uns
veranlassen darüber nachzudenken wie wir
unsererseits die Bedingungen anpassen
können an ein neues globales Umfeld
die EU-Vertreter wollen
Ausnahmeregelungen für europäische
Firmen erreichen viele zweifeln daran
dass das realistisch ist klar dürfte
allerdings sein dass in diesen ohnehin
schwierigen Zeiten keine Seite Interesse
an noch einem großen Konflikt haben kann
und wir sprechen mit Florian neuhahn in
Brüssel Florian worauf muss sich die EU
jetzt einstellen
das ganze hat die Europäer wirklich kalt
erwischt als der US-Präsident dieses
Gesetz im August unterschrieb da hat
sich die eu-kommissionspräsidentin
Ursula von der Leyen noch öffentlich
gefreut es sei doch gut dass die USA
jetzt auch den Klimaschutz massiv
subventionieren und erst langsam ist in
Europäern dann klar geworden dass das
ihre eigene Autoindustrie massiv
benachteiligen wird und jetzt fragt sich
Europa eben wie man darauf am besten
reagiert und da gibt es die einen
angeführt von den Franzosen die da
gleich ist mit Gleichem vergelten wollen
also auch auf massive Subventionen
setzen wollen möglicherweise Schulden
finanziert und möglicherweise auch nur
für europäische Firmen das wäre der
Einstieg in einer neuen Handelskonflikt
oder gar Krieg und es gibt die anderen
angeführt von Deutschland die vor allem
auf diese Gespräche setzen und hoffen
dass die USA noch irgendwelche Ausnahmen
erlauben für europäische Firmen aber es
ist eben alles andere als klar ob das
wirklich gelingt wenn nicht dann steht
die neue transalantische Einigkeit auf
dem Spiel und das wäre gerade in dieser
Weltlage vielleicht der größte
anzunehmende Unfall danke für die
Einschätzung nach Brüssel florian
neuhahn war das
Indien ist auch starker
Wirtschaftspartner Deutschlands
außenminstern baerbock ist dort gerade
zu Besuch und will die Partnerschaft
stärken das Ziel eine engere
Zusammenarbeit in klimaschutzfragen oder
bei der Sicherheitspolitik auch um ein
stärkeres Gegengewicht zu China zu
bilden außerdem soll Indien die
bevölkerungsreichste demokrie der Welt
Demokratie der Welt seine Positionierung
zu Russland überdenken das ist die
Hoffnung von Annalena baerbock aber das
Land erweist sich als selbstbewusster
und ziemlich kompromissloser Partner
Andreas Kühnast
im Berufsverkehr der U-Bahnlinie 4 steht
an diesem Mittag eine deutsche
Ministerin und Neu-Delhi guckt kein
bisschen hin oder vielleicht ein wenig
Annalena baerbock schmeichelt Indien
verwendet den Nahverkehr verbeugt sich
im Tempel und versucht ihre Gastgeber zu
Freunden zu machen wer Box Lob für
Indien ist gleichzeitig als Kritik an
Indiens Rivalen an China zu verstehen
mit Indien verbindet uns eben nicht nur
eine Partnerschaft im wirtschaftlichen
Bereich eine Partnerschaft beim
austausche von Menschen sondern es
verbindet uns eben mit Indien eine
wertepartnerschaft und das ist anders
als mit manch anderen Ländern auch in
der Region der indische Partner teilt
nicht alle Werte vor allem nicht wer Box
nicht die westliche Sicht auf Russlands
Krieg politisch hat sich Indien
enthalten wirtschaftlich versucht es zu
profitieren während Europa etwa
russisches Öl sanktioniert weitet Indien
den Handel mit Russland sogar noch aus
und verweist auf seine energiehungrige
Bevölkerung
Europa trifft seine Entscheidungen
Europa priorisiert seine
Energiebedürfnisse aber bittet uns etwas
anderes zu tun an denn ausgehen
dass sich Indien zumindest verbal von
Russland distanziert muss Barock heute
reichen die indische Regierung ist
genervt von den Fragen nach ihrem
wachsenden Handel mit Russland nach
ihrer nicht eindeutigen Positionierung
zum Krieg die Hoffnung auf Neu-Delhi als
Vermittler als Verbündeten gab hat sich
nicht oder noch nicht erfüllt leichter
wird es für indische Fachkräfte in
Deutschland zu arbeiten ein
mobilitätsabkommen ist das konkrete
Ergebnis von Neu-Delhi
jetzt der Blick in die Ukraine dort gab
es an diesem Montag im ganzen Land
Luftalarm und massive russische Angriffe
der ukrainischen Flugabwehr sei es
gelungen die meisten russischen Raketen
vom Himmel zu holen so der ukrainische
Präsident man sei dabei die
Stromversorgung wieder herzustellen aus
verschiedenen Teilen des Landes wurden
Explosionen gemeldet in saporicia sein
mindestens zwei Menschen getötet worden
so die Behörden die Menschen suchten
Schutz vor den russischen Angriffen wie
hier in der U-Bahn von Kiew
schon vor Monaten hatten die USA und
Kanada ein Embargo gegen russisches Öl
verhängt und jetzt ziehen die EU-Staaten
nach ab heute darf Rohöl aus Russland
nur noch in Ausnahmefällen in die
Europäische Union importiert werden
damit die Maßnahme möglichst Wirkung
zeigt gilt außerdem ein preisdeckel mehr
als 60 Dollar pro Barrel soll russischen
Öl Exporteuren nicht mehr gezahlt werden
diese Obergrenze wäre etwas weniger als
der aktuelle Marktpreis ob der Deckel
Russland wirklich trifft das ist noch
unklar wir wollen das jetzt vertiefen
mit Valerie Haller die ist jetzt bei mir
im Studio Halle Valerie dieser Maßnahmen
die seit heute in Kraft sind was können
die bringen also das könnte Russland
tatsächlich empfindlich treffen Öl ist
die wichtigste Einnahmequelle noch vor
Gas und wenn Russland Öl nur noch für 60
Dollar das Verkaufen kann dann tut das
schon richtig weh die Frage wird
allerdings sein kann Russland auf andere
Abnehmer ausweichen China Indien die
Türkei wir haben ja Interesse nur für
diese Lieferung da braucht man schon
auch eine Infrastruktur und das geht
jetzt nicht von jetzt auf gleich zumal
die meisten Öltanker europäisch beflaggt
und versichert sind und die müssen ja
mitmachen beim preisdeckel ja und die
große Frage Valerie die sich jetzt
aufträgt was macht das mit unserem
Ölpreis also das könnte schon eine
Auswirkung haben auf unseren Ölpreis da
könnte steigen Russland ist normal ein
großer Öllieferant andererseits haben
sich schon viele wegen des Winters mit
Öl eingedeckt außerdem steuern wir auf
eine Rezession zu und das könnte die
Nachfrage natürlich auch ein Stück weit
in Grenzen halten aber preisdeckel und
embargo das ist schon ein Experiment und
ehrlicherweise weiß keiner so ganz genau
wie das ausgeht Valerie vielen Dank für
die Einschätzung ja und auch wegen all
der gerade besprochenen Turbulenzen will
Deutschland unabhängiger werden und
sucht Energie Alternativen
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck reißt
deshalb mehrere Tage lang durch südliche
Afrika die erste Station heißt
Namibia die ehemalige deutsche Kolonie
verfügt über alle Voraussetzungen die
sie für die Produktion von grünem
Wasserstoff so interessant machen
Patricia Wiedemeier
Sonne Wind und vor allem Platz davon hat
Namibia reichlich mit ein Grund für den
deutschen Wirtschaftsminister mit einer
Delegation nach Windhoek der Hauptstadt
von Namibia zu reisen heute erste
Gespräche mit dem Präsidenten und dem
Energieminister über eine Zusammenarbeit
im Bereich grüner Wasserstoff
wir haben die Ressourcen aber wir
brauchen natürlich auch globale Partner
die uns unterstützen damit es wirklich
funktioniert die deutsche Regierung ist
da ein guter Partner
wichtig ist dass die Energieversorgung
für Namibia und das Nachbarland
Südafrika durch dieses Projekt stärker
robuster und klimafreundlicher wird und
das was übrig bleibt die Energie die
übrig bleibt die würden wir dann
tatsächlich gerne abnehmen es geht darum
dass hier in Namibia mit Wind und Sonnen
Energie Wasser in Sauerstoff und
Wasserstoff aufgespalten wird
der daraus entstehende grüne wasserstoff
kann dann mit Spezialschiffen oder
Tanklastern umgewandelt transportiert
werden die Rede ist von Investitionen
von rund 10 Milliarden Euro wir reden
hier eine großen Ordnung von ungefähr
sieben Gigawatt einer Erneuerbaren ja
das ist mehr als wir in Deutschland
insgesamt im letzten Jahr installiert
haben es sind große Chancen einseitige
Abhängigkeiten wie zum Beispiel von
Russland zu verringern aber lieferbar
wäre grüner Wasserstoff wohl erst ab
es ist ein sinnvolles Projekt aber eher
für die Mittelfrist das heißt in einigen
Jahren erst man muss sich ja stellen das
ist wirklich grüner Wasserstoff der
hergestellt ist mit Ökostrom und
nachhaltigkeitszertifikate eingehalten
dann ist es sinnvoll es könnte ein
Projekt werden das beiden Seiten nutzt
die Weichen dafür sie sind gestellt
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat deutlich
gemacht dass Deutschland
US-Kampfjets des Typs F35 kaufen will
sie sollen veraltete Tornados ablösen
zum Preis von rund 10 Milliarden Euro
für Aufsehen hatte am Wochenende ein
Papier aus dem Verteidigungsministerium
gesorgt dass auf diverse risikenverweist
dazu erklärte das Ministerium heute sein
normal dass es im aktuellen
Planungsstadium Faktoren gebe die man
noch nicht vollständig im Griff habe
jetzt zu einer Tat die fassungslos macht
bei der aber noch Fragen offen sind auf
dem Schulweg werden zwei Mädchen 13 und
14 Jahre alt von einem Mann angegriffen
und schwer verletzt die 14-Jährige
stirbt im Krankenhaus
Tatort ist die kleine Gemeinde
Illerkirchberg südlich von Ulm dort
laufen jetzt die Ermittlungen Eva
Schiller berichtet
es ist schwer zu begreifen warum das
14-jährige Mädchen sterben musste auf
ihrem Weg zur Schule es passiert gegen
7:30 Uhr zwei Mädchen 13 und 14 werden
brutal wohl mit einem Messer attackiert
und schwer verletzt dann läuft der Täter
in das nahegelegene Gebäude eine
Unterkunft für geflüchtete als die
Polizei des Gebäude betreten hat traf
sie dort auf drei Männer aus deren Kreis
ist der Täter zu vermuten der
mutmaßliche Täter trägt bei der
Festnahme ein Messer bei sich der
Polizei zufolge handelt es sich bei ihm
um einen Asylbewerber aus Eritrea die
schwer verletzten Mädchen werden in die
Klinik gebracht die 14-Jährige stirbt
dann Nachmittag an ihren Verletzungen
als Familienvater natürlich dann auch
gleich an die Familien momentan ist ist
es so dass wir alle in unterschock
stehen ob es eine wahllose Attacke war
oder Täter und Opfer sich kannten
zu den Hintergründen zu möglichen
Kontakten das läuft alles noch da können
wir noch gar nicht sagen wir wissen
nicht ob sich die Personen untereinander
gekannt haben bedrückende Stille hängt
über Oberkirchberg es ist die Frage nach
dem Warum nach dem Motiv die Angehörige
Polizei und Bewohner umtreibt
jetzt nach Belgien wo sie versuchen ein
Trauma zu bewältigen sechseinhalb Jahre
nach der Anschlagsserie die Brüssel
erschütterte die belgische Hauptstadt am
Morgen des 22 März 2016
islamistische selbstmordatentäter töten
am Flughafen und in der Metro 32
Menschen hunderte werden verletzt heute
hat der Mammutprozess gegen die
mutmaßlichen Täter begonnen Isabel
das Jana und ihre Tochter Miley heute
zusammen im Park spielen können ist
nicht selbstverständlich jana war im
siebten Monat schwanger und in der
U-Bahn unterwegs als dort eine Bombe
explodierte
ich habe nur an mein Baby gedacht und
gar nicht gemerkt wie schwer ich selbst
verletzt bin ich wollte nur ins
Krankenhaus und wissen ob es meinem Baby
gut geht
22 März 2016 in der Schalterhalle des
Brüsseler Flughafen starntem detoniert
um 7:58 Uhr eine Bombe 10 Sekunden
später eine zweite
in der Metrostation malweg explodiert um
9 Uhr 11 eine dritte Bombe insgesamt
sterben 32 Menschen mehr als 300 werden
verletzt
heute beginnt in Brüssel der Prozess
gegen zehn Männer die für die Anschläge
verantwortlich sein sollen
es sieht damit ein mega-prozess weil es
sich um schwerwiegende Taten handelt die
die gesamte Bevölkerung erschüttert
haben es handelt sich um ein
Schwurgericht und somit haben die Bürger
die Möglichkeit über die Schuld zu
entscheiden
sechs der zehn Angeklagten wurden
bereits in Pariser terror-prozess
verurteilt unter anderem Salah ab des
Lamm und Mohammed sabrini wohl zwei der
Köpfe hinter den Brüsseler Anschlägen
für die Opfer ist es wichtig dass nun
auch eine Verurteilung in Belgien
stattfindet
genug Raum für die Opfer geben viele
wollen Aussagen erklären was an diesem
Tag passiert ist was sie erlebt haben
das ist ihnen sehr wichtig
mit dem Urteil ist frühestens im Juni
zurechnen
das ohne Freiwillige in dieser
Gesellschaft vieles nicht funktionieren
würde ist nichts Neues ziemlich aktuell
ist allerdings dass der Krieg in Europa
Energiekrise und Inflation die notfäller
Menschen noch drängender gemacht hat
heute am Tag des Ehrenamtes dankte
Bundespräsident Steinmeier allen die wie
er sagt ohne viel Aufhebens anpacken und
hat mehrere von ihnen mit dem
Bundesverdienstkreuz geehrt Jana Becker
hat einen der ausgezeichneten besucht
Ralf Hamm kann sich sein Leben ohne
Ehrenamt nicht mehr vorstellen sein
Engagement beginnt 2012 nachdem er
zweimal schwer erkrankt war musste der
Mülheimer sein damaligen Job im Software
und IT-Bereich aufgeben du fällst ja
erstmal in ein Loch im gesundheitlich
wirtschaftlich persönlich und ohne eine
sinnvolle Aufgabe geht der Tag ja nicht
rum und dadurch war ich richtig froh
dass ich dann in der Zeitung von dem
gelesen habe die Idee zu dem du stammt
aus den USA Ralf Hamm hat das Konzept in
Deutschland groß gemacht wir sammeln
alte Laptops und Tablets in Deutschland
gibt größenordnungsmäßig ca 30 Millionen
davon und die nehmen wir von Privat und
Unternehmen entgegen Helfer löschen alte
Daten reparieren und bespielen die
Geräte mit über 300 Lernprogrammen wer
mitmachen möchte kann sich online
registrieren die aufbereiteten Laptops
und Tablets gehen dann an Kinder und
Jugendprojekte im Innen- und Ausland die
Junior uni-ruhr hat vor kurzem 12
Laptops bekommen die Kinder freuen sich
über die Spenden weil man so viele
darauf ausprobieren kann ist macht Spaß
insgesamt zweieinhalb Tausend Schulen
und Projekte hat lap du bereits
ausgestattet
langfristig wünsche ich mir einfach dass
irgendwann in hoffentlich vielen vielen
Jahren dann sich auch Helfer
entsprechend Warmlaufen um in die
Fußstapfen zu treten dass der Verein
dann auch über wie viele Jahrzehnte noch
weitergeführt wird bis dahin will sich
Ralf Hamm weiter für digitale Teilhabe
und Nachhaltigkeit einsetzen
Dramatik bei der Fußball-WM
Elfmeterschießen zwischen Japan und
Kroatien am Ende jubeln die Kroaten
starke Nerven dann war reicht's auch
Vize-Weltmeister kroatien hat als fünfte
Mannschaft die Runde der letzten Acht
erreicht und Japan den Traum vom ersten
Viertelfinale Einzug verdorben die
Kroaten zunächst den Rückstand gewann
schließlich nach Elfmeterschießen mit
4:2
kurz vor der Pause die Japaner mit ihrer
lieblingseckenvariante der Freiburger
duan mit einer scharfen Flanke
kroatische Verwirrung Abpraller Treffer
bei Eder mit der 1:0 Pausenführung für
Japan Kroatien macht es nach dem Wechsel
ganz ähnlich aus dem Spiel heraus eine
halbweltflanke
parisic in der 55 Minute mit dem 1:1
Ausgleich und die WM Finalisten von 2018
setzen nach Luca Modric zwingt japanser
zu einer Glanzparade es bleibt beim eins
zu eins nach regulärer Spielzeit und
auch nach Verlängerung
Elfmeterschießen Yoshida als Vierter
Schütze unter Druck zwei 11-fach
Kroatiens Torwart bereits gehalten
und livakowitsch pariert auch diesen
pasulic kann jetzt alles klar machen
und er machte es drei zu eins im
Elfmeterschießen Kroatien im
Viertelfinale
und beim Deutschen Fußball-Bund da
beginnt die Aufarbeitung des erneut
enttäuschenden Abschneidens bei einem
Großereignis die Diskussionen über
personelle Veränderungen sind längst
entfacht besonders im Fokus der
Geschäftsführer
Oliver Bierhoff ist stark umstritten
seitdem die Erfolge der DFB-Elf
ausbleiben drei schlechte Turniere
nacheinander wobei sich manche Fehler
wie die Kommunikationsmängel auch noch
wiederholt haben 2018 war es der Umgang
mit Mesut Özils Erdogan besucht diesmal
die Diskussion um die one love-binde
Punkt 2 die sportliche Ausbildung in den
letzten Jahren hat Oliver Bierhoff zwar
immer mal wieder Alarm geschlagen was
die Nachwuchsarbeit betrifft doch getan
hat sich offenbar nicht genug die
Probleme vor allem in der Abwehr waren
auch bei dieser WM evident
seit 2018 hat Bierhoff seine Macht im
DFB weiter ausgebaut ist zuständig für
alle Nationalmannschaften und die
Akademie jetzt steht er im Visier derer
die eine Veränderung für notwendig
erachten
die Trainersuche des VfB Stuttgart ist
beendet Bruno Labbadia übernimmt nach
fast 10 Jahren zum zweiten Mal die
Schwaben um den Abwärtstrend zu stoppen
dies war den 56-Jährigen auch schon mit
dem VfL Wolfsburg und auch mit Hertha
BSC gelungen jeweils wurde der
Klassenerhalt gesichert in Stuttgart
unterschrieb der nun einen Vertrag bis
Juni 2025 und erstes Spiel erst
Herausforderung gegen Mainz so ein gut
sechs Wochen dann vielen Dank Christin
das noch von uns in der Nacht Schnee
Regen und Glätte Details hat gleich
gegen Viertel von neun gibt es heute
journal mit Marietta Slomka schönen Dank
fürs zuschauen und noch einen
entspannten Montagabend für Sie
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter dieses kleine tief
hier das brachte heute Schnee teilweise
auch im Westen dahinter kommt Regen rein
das ganze verabschiedet sich allmählich
Richtung Südosten und das Tief wandert
Weg dahinter kommt erneut kalte Luft
diesmal aus dem Nordwesten schauen uns
die Details an in der Nacht also Regen
und Schnee quer über den Mittelgebirgen
teilweise und das wandert allmählich
nach Südosten auch Richtung Bayern
Richtung Berchtesgadener Land auch
schneefallen der ersten Nachthälfte
verabschiedet sich allmählich dahinter
wird es dann allmählich trockener und
kalt Glätte damit müssen Sie rechnen -1
- 6 Grad hier im Süden und vier Grad
Richtung Nordsee ja und morgen liegt
dann das Regen und schneefallgebiete
Richtung Erzgebirge und auch im Osten
regnet es von der Nordsee her kommen die
Schauer rein mit der Kaltluft und ganzen
Süden lockert es sogar auf mit
Sonnenschein bei Temperaturen von 1 bis
6 Grad deutschlandweit die kommenden
Tage weitere shower sind unterwegs und
zwar von Nordwesten her bei 0 bis 6 Grad
und Donnerstag gibt sogar
graupelgewitter und damit ein schöner
Abend